I don't think in 20 years of doing this, that
I've done one thing that takes sick people
and makes them well people nearly as incredibly
is this does.
You can dispute the ickiness of this, but
I don't think anybody can dispute anymore
the efficacy of this.
The science is clear.
It's like a miracle.
Ryan Schneider was a healthy 25-year-old when
he developed a mysterious, debilitating condition.
I was being treated for what I now know is
chronic pelvic pain.
I was seeing urologists for it that were trying
to diagnose it, and they thought it was other
conditions such as an STD or a UTI.
And so they were just prescribing me antibiotic
after antibiotic.
And I didn't know at the time how devastating
those are on your body.
And so what the antibiotics did is kill all
of the healthy bacteria, if you will.
Every morning I was waking up vomiting before
work, and I would still go to work and just
feel terrible all day.
It basically made my immune system similar
to that of somebody who's infected with HIV
or AIDS or cancer.
It was from a stool sample that I finally
found that I had C. diff.
Clostridium difficile, or C. diff, is a bacterium
that lives in the colon and can cause a number
of severe symptoms such as diarrhea, fever,
weight loss, nausea, and pain.
It affects about a half million patients a
year.
And it kills an estimated 15,000 to 30,000
people annually.
Normally I'm 175 pounds.
I weigh about 155 right now.
So I've lost a ton of weight in the last year.
Most people with C. diff, which is what Ryan
has, the dominant symptom is diarrhea.
It's really horrible, horrible diarrhea.
They're tired, they lose weight.
They're fatigued, they have a belly ache.
It can be life-threatening.
People can die of this.
None of the medications help with my symptoms.
Are you taking anything else?
I am on Prozac now.
I'm seeing a therapist because it's just been
really draining, having this disease for so
long.
My appetite's not good.
I'm feeling nauseous all the time.
I'm having trouble sleeping.
I'm anxious.
Many people with Ryan's condition have turned
to a unique procedure known as a fecal transplant,
which involves taking poop from a healthy
donor and inserting it into a patient's colon
to recolonize good bacteria into their system.
The population that we're treating this way,
this is their last resort.
They've been sick for a minimum of six months.
And this cures them.
The classic case that I take care of has an
over 90% success rate.
A nonprofit in Massachusetts called Open Biome
works with doctors across the country to provide
them with screened fecal matter.
They're essentially a poop bank.
So we process stool from healthy donors and
send it out to hospitals all over the country
for use in the medical procedure fecal microbiota
transplantation.
Can you tell us a bit about the process?
We have a three-step process for becoming
a donor.
Overall the pass rate is about 4%.
So it's about twice as hard to become a donor
as it is to get into Harvard.
So you go through 109-point clinical assessment.
If you clear that, and most people don't,
then you go on and bring in a stool sample.
And if you pass that, then you go in and get
a blood draw.
Because we invest quite a bit of money and
time and finding donors, we pay the donors
40 bucks a sample.
For every poop we've got to process it within
an hour of passage.
Once material's collected, processed, then
it sits in our freezer and quarantined for
60 days.
So it's sort of under medical supervision
during the collection process.
And then if they pass at the end, then we
release the material for use and we'll send
it out to clinics.
I think the average is about 150 to 200 grams.
The biggest sample we've ever seen is 581
grams, which is just ginormous.
Like that almost completely filled these containers.
So I just weighed this sample here.
I grab one of these filter bags.
So this is just pumping the liquid through
a filter here.
Do some of the donors have a smell that you
recognize?
Some donors, I would say, are generally stinkier
than others, but I wouldn't say they have
a trademark smell per se.
So it's no longer in that log form.
We broke it all up.
I'm just using this pipette, and we're just
transferring the liquid into the bottles.
We're ready to freeze these, and that's it.
The minimum size is enough to create one treatment,
but of course, bigger is always better.
We encourage fiber.
We're dealing with life and death issues for
patients, and we take that really, really
seriously.
But we also like to recognize that there's
a pretty funny element to what we do as well,
and particularly with our donors, get them
motivated and engaged.
What we've done is we've given kind of an
avatar to each donor.
And so there's a bunch of poop-related puns,
like Albus Dumpledor or--
Ninja Turdle.
Scooby Doo Doo's a good one.
It's nice to have a bit of fun.
How did you find out about donating your feces
for science?
They had a flier up that they were passing
around.
We were kind of standing around laughing about
it, and it was saying, $40 for every poop,
and I was thinking, like, man, this sounds
great.
How do you collect a poop donation?
There is a little, looks like a cooler container.
It sits in the toilet bowl with a little kind
of rack.
So you pretty much just go like you normally
would, as long as your aim is all right.
It gets in the bowl and then you just pop
a lid on it and that's that.
It was really weird at first, especially the
first couple samples I turned in.
But everyone so nice, without a filter, in
terms of talking about poop around here, that
I quickly adjusted to it.
So now it's second nature.
Especially at the end of every week they tell
you, here's how many people you saved this
week.
I mean, it was something I was doing every
day anyway.
Why not help people?
After learning about the success rate of fecal
transplants, Ryan is preparing to undergo
the procedure.
Do you feel weird about having somebody else's
fecal material put into your body?
It was weird at first, but I don't even think
about that at all any more, because the way
I feel now is weird.
I want to feel back to normal.
I don't really care what it takes to get that.
I just want to feel normal again.
This is done pretty simply with a colonoscopy.
So we flush them out.
They get an IV.
They get sedated.
I take a colonoscope, I drive it to the top
of their colon, and then we have syringes
that are full of replacement poop.
And we literally inject 250 ccs or so of poop.
That's about a soda can.
It's somewhere-- the volume's about 10 ounces
of poop.
We go all the way to the top, we inject it
inside.
We take the camera out.
What's success for you?
Like, let's say 100%?
80%?
Yeah, I mean, if I was just not having diarrhea
any more after the surgery, and not having
pain any more, that would be success.
To see a negative test for C. diff.
So it took us eight months to treat the first
thousand patients.
And then it took us four months to treat the
next thousand patients.
So we wouldn't be surprised if in the next
year we're treating more like 5,000 or 10,000
patients a year.
Our mission is to change the epidemiology
of C. diff, and really start to make a dent
in the overall national mortality of the disease.
This episode is a part of Seeker Stories.
To see all the stories we post here, be sure
to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.